[Music]
[Applause]
can everybody hear me okay good I was
worried the mic was not working okay
well thank you everybody for coming to
see my talk a little bit so slight
change of pace you'll see a few themes
in it but the main question I want to
answer and unfortunately I missed boss's
talk so if some of this is repetitive I
was right here just let me know
it was repetitive it's what's in your je
s a little bit about myself really
quickly I'm a Technical Evangelist and
epidemics um prior worked some
distributed systems companies like
mesosphere Red Hat and they keep me out
of production now I had some very
large-scale corruption issues and
different types of databases and I'm not
good at math so slider calculations if
you're familiar with them I'm not I
don't know you divide by 8 divided by 16
it's kind of the same thing to me so
what's not so what are we gonna learn
today
pretty interactive quick quick show of
hands if you can't caught Patras talk
about extensions how many of you
actually want NPM install the extension
if you're in the talk did anybody try
that right after so we okay a little
less than I expected but the next
question would be you know did you do it
on your work laptop right ah see and say
what are some takeaways that we're gonna
learn about today is that don't add
things willy-nilly all right and I'm
gonna keep this is gonna be very clear
do not add things willy-nilly into your
project I've been bit in a few times and
some of my peers have been bit in a few
times also a lot of my a lot of my
background I was a je a Java like a cor
distributed systems engineer for on
several Java projects and what you know
one transitioning into node what were
some analogies I was missing and looking
for and really it shows the importance
of this conference and how quickly the
Java Script your systems changing and
also what are the equivalents right so
you know Java Java fanboy here like hey
if you're preaching about all this
what's you know what's going on and so
you thought this was a JavaScript
conference right what is Duke doing
the screen in Java so a lot if you look
at the lineage of the Java language of
je from when it came out in 1999 to now
is that what really pushed the language
Ford was a governing body right so if
there was a change have a very tight
structure in the Java language and so if
there was a change they have something
called a JCP a Java community of
practice and people would vote on future
editions the closest thing that
JavaScript has is the ECMA right and so
JavaScript aka ECMAScript is the
governing body in the standards
organization and so as we have current
road issues I think we remember just an
eight right now or nine and 2018 is that
that's that governing body right so
without a governing particular strong
governing body how do you get standards
into the language and so let's take a
look at what would be you do be a common
theme here if you're going to start
building a more distributed system your
npm install' is gonna get quite you know
quite big right so what are some things
okay so as a core services developer
that I am what are some things that I
expect in my particular packages or how
my application interacts and so
transactions right so the the common
myth that server-side JavaScript it's
not good in transactions actually
because of the ecosystem it's not true
anymore if you think about what a
transaction is pretend I'm dealing out
money to people in the room okay did you
did I give you money yes no that's what
most people kind of pop in there how
about transaction is but if you take a
look at how an actual transaction
actually occurs or what actually
transaction means when you look at
system boundaries applications kind of
look like this right so it's more than
this front-end we might be taking it
data from sensors you might be taking in
data from other users or inputs there
might be a message broker attached to it
there's definitely databases that are
attached to it and all of these systems
have to have to interact with each other
and so what what one of the the core
differences between the Java ecosystem
well I would call it one of the top
three things that put Java in the
enterprise it something called JTA under
the Java transaction API and what the
Java transaction API is and there is an
ogee a circle instance but what the Java
transaction API is is that it allows
even non Java clients right so you go
database and they were to see they have
the ability to do a rollback in a commit
right so you can even participate in
something called X a transaction is
every transaction so if you go back to
our diagram here we're crossing several
transaction boundaries we're interacting
with systems JTA is what put it on the
map but we are at a JavaScript
conference right so what one of how in
JavaScript land that we have and so a
lot of times this is delegated to the
actual database right and so a lot of
the concurrency or a lot of the
transaction handling it's actually
delegated to the database and why is it
delegated to the database is that so if
you take a look at how your work is
actually distributed and here's a
perfect example a node you might have
multiple instances of uh nodes let's say
a client or a node a piece of server
infrastructure but the incoming
transactions the the incoming a let's
say partitions are all managed by
database right so did someone pay you
money well yes we have a record here in
the database and so just skip skipping
along a little bit about you know what's
just why this is important you know
captain consistency availability
partition tolerance again you know core
services developer you're looking at
these particular things now in Java land
there's so there's just another
difference in how Java Script is handled
is in threads right and so in the drama
the Java rendition there's a concept of
pools right so if you have an incoming
request you have the ability to pull
those threads so the JVM gets bigger and
bigger and bigger not like in the and
nodejs it's Agnon on blocking thread or
they have threatened and the covers out
the integer written but in the
JavaScript rendition is something called
promise right so how many people use
promises in here before
okay good seems like there's most people
use promises the promises were something
that was new to me a few years ago and
that again was something that was
blocking me from doing doing development
that's say okay we can't you know we
don't have ability to call back but for
folks who haven't used a promise
basically what I promise is you can
either succeed or fail at one time right
and so it's like a callback on steroids
and a very particular another of large
promise package is Bluebird jazz so
Bluebird jeaious allows you to had hop
types as callbacks is anybody in here
use Bluebird
Wow good very good it was again this is
new to me a year ago but the reason why
I bring this up in these particular
features up is that as we're going along
this journey okay how do I
have you know how do I have a proper
promise if I happen in traffic database
another client and all this entire time
we keep adding things into our package
of JSON right so what ends up happening
eventually is that this package keeps
growing grow so keep that in the back of
your head when going along what kind of
last about you know how work just
actually distributed well and why is
this problem becoming even more
important is that if you take a look at
where your applications are actually
headed comparing it to a Java model it
actually looks like this right so no
more and more out if you're looking at
JavaScript or distributed application
there's way more renditions of your
application out there so if I taking
okay I have a java application that
might be deployed one place your
JavaScript application as here so the
isolation is handled by the container
right it's distributed multiple places
so as your application gets more and
more dependencies it actually goes more
places taking a look at some more of
these dependencies again so what-what
would be something that a core Java
developer be looking for debugging and
tracing right so if I was in Java land
you can have aid distributed tracer and
part of the distribute tracing is
instrumentation also so you can
introspect the bytecode
but what about in the nodejs land right
about the dough's equivalents one of my
favorite projects out there right now is
something called Jaeger I like because
of the name I thought I'd run me the
alcohol race I was like oh yeah this is
a really cool project but a little bit
about Jaeger anybody familiar is again
pull I love to pull the audience anybody
who's used Jaeger in here before or okay
so that I can add some value here so
vaguer is a cloud native compute
foundation project it came from uber and
so over it if you look at how their
applications written maybe 2008 it was
very heavy in Java but what as they
became a bigger organization they
clearly became more polyglot and so they
have to support other languages like
Python or especially nodejs now and so
one of the limiting factors for them was
the ability to get trace information
from their nodejs applications and so
you can act up I'm wrong suggest taking
a look at Jaeger if you have a
distributed application or let's say a
application of scale is that you can
actually implement a Jaeger client to be
included in your node application Oh in
your node application and so you can
interact with traps right so okay part
of the trouble when I was making single
page or known applications in the
beginning was the hooks for us to get
user data out was tremendous it took as
much horsepower for us to instrument the
application that it was the build
features a lot of us I was working in
the federal sector for this and a
project like eager with really important
that help captures specific information
and now getting into kind of the gist of
the talk right so okay why is this guy
babbling a lot about Java the whole time
it gets to what I call the fog of
development and what is a fog of
development let's all pretend we all
started a new project right and so we
the very first time we run now spotted a
few folks about this earlier today we
started a new project today we're all in
the same journey and we have to learn
about how is our project structured went
the first the very first time I did no
development but I think there was like
300 packages in the package.json I was
like what is this how do I even go about
figuring out what's what and this is in
the fog of development right people is
kind of willy-nilly again don't
willy-nilly include things we're adding
package to the package.json or we didn't
know why certain things weren't
resolving like okay go ahead and add
those other packages well until we beat
it together to sort of work but
comparing so let's look at the problem
again I missed some of AUSA's talk so
I'm gonna talk about how NPM resolves
things if any of that's changed in 2018
just tell me I missed part of his talk
if you look at what what I call
dependency health so if you've been
working in software for a while you'll
see that oh you know what do you
definitely include things that you don't
have that in your software project
you've written so quite a quote I didn't
write half of these things I included
them as dependencies dependency hell in
Java and there is a a particular
hierarchy that you have so this this is
a typical Java project but there is a
hierarchy that the Java bootloader will
take to resolve class resolution or
class conflicts and not so much in the
NPM Lance if you take a look at what
mental picture this is what it looks
like in Java typical trace what it looks
like for real estate but a jquery
rendition it's actually very complicated
the packages are very incent you another
that let's say you're working on
particular this is actually a profile of
an application that oh we call jQuery
eight times or there
eight renditions of the package in there
and so this really loose itself to some
very funky problems that you have and so
this might be a little bit cliche to say
here but and anybody in the room runs
this problem so you you work on an
application and in the JavaScript land
its first to load will win right so when
the ast loads it's actually the first to
load that will win so let's say in a
this really gets them to share around if
it worked on your computer versus at
work it doesn't work in production if I
was writing a particular package or a
particularly on my desktop it might have
certain performance implications that oh
you know what my my first package loaded
before my second package enough let's
say my first package had jQuery one
point two point four and there's some
other renditions had one point three you
might start getting inconsistent states
right saying oh we don't know exactly
why this particular function failed in
production because it was working fine
on my laptop but what it's really hard
to debug like oh there was a transitive
dependency to another version of jQuery
that lookout loaded in the browser first
and that's actually something very very
hard to tell
and so like answering this very basic
question you know what is in your npm
install so so what are some things that
we can do or what are some things we can
take immediately as teams to start
addressing this particular sue what's in
your npm install so the first thing is
is hygiene right so unfortunately Tyler
couldn't make the talk he was in talking
so some of this will overlap with
Tyler's talk but he's not trying to
steal so much a his sundar from earlier
is that you what answering this
infringing question it really comes down
to Deb practices in def hygiene right so
the JavaScript ecosystem is it's not
immune to certain types of attacks like
typos squatting you know let's say I
made a particular package called jja why
Cory like a name and someone mistyped
that I can really inject nefarious items
into your NPM install but first thing is
really understand where your particular
package just came from and this this is
pretty true you know when you read an
emptyness all for the first time when we
look on three well I got 300 300 75
packages is really asking some questions
why right so it goes going back to dev
hygiene hey why are these particular
packages in there but a lot of time to
be coming to projects after the fact
right and it becomes really hard to
answer that question why did someone
include this why did someone not include
this why why is there a JSON file you
know 400 lines long to even do at MPM
install I gets very difficult the first
thing is actually getting a bill of
materials right for that particular
project so if you can Javal and you can
look at the dependency tree or look at
like a maven install for the coordinates
in the npm install' again understanding
those transit dependencies to get a
little bit harder harder to do you know
let's see here and so going back to you
know what's actually in your npm install
the profiling becomes extremely
important does anybody use any sort of
profiler but they're in JavaScript
packages or so a few people use a
profile I got it yeah what's really
important when the profile profiler can
do imagine go back to you just started
on that particular project it's actually
looking at the culture is right saying
okay let's figure out exactly what's
being used where cuz if what happens and
it might be it's kind of a delegate that
it's easy to include certain things
right it's a JavaScript it's plain text
so I can include anything on the fly
really taking a look at into deeper
context what am I actually including
right what does this functionality and
having this maybe a go going back to
practical experience oh you know part of
our stand-up meetings or dead meetings
anytime you're introducing a particular
change is why you're introducing that
particular change or why why do we need
it because you can actually introduce
yourself to undo risk right so from a
license standpoint am i including
something that has a nefarious license
am i including something that has a
particular vulnerability the big one and
no js' was eastland so they have a type
of squad or sat there and was able to
intercept and so that that particular
information is key and I think there's a
lot of work that the NPM community is
doing around that every round that arena
let's see here so some other tooling
that you can use when if something quick
and easy and dirty you can use for free
I don't have a slide for this but it's
called
a wasp but the open web app security
group they have something called
dependency checker right so it'll
actually introspect your package JSON
and give you a list of all in appendices
so if your team's not using a wasp's
dependency checker that would be
something I would highly recommend it
looks I'll give you a printout of all
the dependencies that you have and also
something
for free and that they actually tie back
the package information to mitre CVE so
if I see a CVE show of hands like if you
know what a CBE is so okay you may be
better so more education so a CVS it's
something called a common vulnerability
enumeration right and so what a CVA is
is that if a defect or a particular
vulnerabilities found there's a way to
report it there's certain aspects that
how severe it is there's a score right
so it's a metric how use we're impacting
how much it can it be remotely launched
and so it does SUVs built for
vulnerabilities now what if you if you
might have if used github and this is
going off off kilter here but for using
github you might be getting as email
notifications Oh a particular package in
your github repo is vulnerable to CVE
XYZ this is exactly what a whilst with
Penske checker is doing for that so
great tool to use to give you give you a
call stack for that but other other
tooling that's out there let me see what
we got going on sue firm from a trans
that were from a particular performance
standpoint there's there several
profilers that are out there will help
you a catalog the application take a
take a profiling look at it there is a
commercial version just free plug I've
worked for epidemic so our profiler
actually will help intercept the call
trace and give you a pretty clean clean
out of what's actually being called I
think I blew through everything in like
twenty minutes going through but I
wanted to be a little more interactive I
do have little flamingos so that's
something I was gonna do before the talk
but didn't get time to do it was I was
gonna make a fake project called project
flamingo if you can see my shirt there's
flamingos here and just see how many
people would actually download it and
just to prove a point that hey don't
install things willy-nilly I was gonna
make up some very good store like oh
yeah my flamingo and the associated
Flocker project that I have with it we
really solve a lot of your tracing
problems that you have it'll do mocks
relief efficiently and you know you're
going to worry about things and just try
to get metrics on how many people
actually after a talk did npm install
install flamingo ryan say oh you had no
idea what I just did
made it look cool but what was it so but
now something I didn't get to do right
before the talk and I have a little pink
flamingos I was gonna hand out to people
who had questions but I would like to
open up for questions if anybody has
questions I know I threw a lot of kind
of disparate information at the folks in
the audience maybe practices that I've
missed if you ask a question I would
give you a flamingo
does anybody have one in the audience of
lingo you can show yeah do you want a
cool flu bug someone asked me a question
earlier yeah oh okay
yeah any questions any comments any
thoughts what is this guy talking about
Java to Josh your conference well I got
a blue bird is that it has you can
actually associate types with the
callbacks and so it again being a being
full disclosure being a fan of type
languages I might want to associate a
certain type of error a blue bird right
saying okay the error exception for I'm
gonna pretend we're trying to get the
weather might be a certain type of cast
that we have and so instead of having a
generic blue bird allow you to have a
specific type saying oh this is a
whether or not found exception so big
fan of it co-worker turned me on to blue
bird so like a lot flamingo for you sir
hey did anybody else have any questions
if not a warm round of applause it was
there anything else that you had no
those it then yeah a warm and applause -
Ravi
[Applause]